Yesterday, I talked generally about the
White House press cause apparent inability
or lack of desire to ask serious questions
of White House Press Secretary Jen Psaki.
We talked yesterday about the dogs and cats
questions from the previous day. Today,
I want to drill into a two minute exchange between
Jen Psaki and Fox News reporter Peter Doocy. Now,
I'm going to admit up front, because I think it's
more interesting, if I'm honest with you, there is
a kernel of a good topic here that Peter tries to
bring up, but he's so blinded by his desperation
to be hysterical and histrionic and and make
the exchange as confrontational and dramatic
as possible. That would could be an interesting
topic. Gets lost in the noise of hyperbole.
I won't say more. Let's just hear the
question and then we'll talk about it.
ABC tells these migrant shelter facilities that
they can be at full capacity if they are careful
about covid many of them do. But when the CDC
tells schools that they can open in person at full
capacity, many of them don't. Is there a school in
particular that you have as an example that didn't
do that or most schools in this country
at full capacity with in-person learning?
So the question in general is fair, but he asks
it in a completely dishonest, deceptive and
needlessly dramatic way. He says, how can the same
CDC be saying child migrant detention facilities
at the border can be open at full capacity, but
schools can't open at full capacity because it's
too dangerous? The fair part of this question
is that in both schools and migrant centers,
both have the potential to have a lot of
kids crowded together and we have a pandemic.
Why can one be open and the other one can't?
That's a perfectly fair kernel of a question.
Now, the circumstances, of course, are
completely different. Kids in schools,
most of them have parents. Most of the
possibility of remote learning, not all.
I understand there's communication between schools
and parents and kids. There's an apparatus where
the relationship is completely different. The
migrant children at the border, you can't say
we're going to do remote border facilities
where you will be with your parents and we
assume you will join the border facility like it
doesn't even compute. It doesn't make any sense.
The circumstances are completely different. In
both cases. The CDC has put out guidelines and
recommendations. The reason the guidelines aren't
the same is because the scenarios are completely
different and what's possible is completely
different. But Peter is desperate to have these
gotcha moments. And so what is actually a good
topic gets lost to the hyperbole and histrionic
questions. Let's continue with it.
Are was there a specific school,
though, that is not following the
CDC guidelines of of implementing
the mitigation steps so they can reopen?
The CDC is saying schools you can be at
every school can be at full
capacity with the CDC guidelines.
The CDC guidelines is to be clear, because
I think this is very important to be very
clear and specific on. They gave eight mitigation
steps that schools can take to safely reopen. A
number of schools have actually recently reopened
schools and Washington, D.C. Some have schools in
many districts across the country, but each school
district needs to make the decision about whether
they are able to take those mitigation steps.
The president has also been clear some of these
school districts need additional funding.
There's a hundred and sixty billion dollars
in this package that he's going to sign
into law later this week. Secretary of
Education will be quite focused on working
with school districts to help them reopen.
But more school districts are reopening.
More kids are in classrooms every single day.
So Jen Psaki points out lots of schools aren't
open because they haven't met the guidelines.
Some schools haven't met the guidelines because
they can't afford to meet the guidelines without
the covid relief money, which was finally passed
yesterday. So many schools are soon going to have
the money to do what the CDC recommends and to
get open. Like that's substantive. That's that's
important. This is separate from what makes
sense. Now, you know, we've talked about
does it make sense or not to open schools?
Does the immigration policy make sense or not?
I just want to focus on the hypocrisy of
Peter Doocy that's created when in reality,
these are very different circumstances. He's
blinded by his unquenchable thirst for drama,
maybe his desire to impress his dad, who's also
a Fox News host. But he he keeps going and then
he changes his approach a little bit.
But since they are not all back from an
administration position or from your
perspective, have the Border Patrol
unions and the HHS unions been. Easier
to work with than the teachers unions.
I think that's a little bit of
mixing different circumstances.
I would say that if children all in tight
quarters, I mean, a classroom, but not quite.
Not quite.
So Jen Saki's opinion of whether
it's easier to work with Border Patrol or teachers
unions is really irrelevant. But eventually Peter
gets to how he should have started, which is that
both the border migrant centers and the schools
are children in tight quarters. That's true.
That's the similarity. What is different such
that we have different guidelines? That's a fair
starting point. It's not the way he went about it.
Here's just the last few moments of this.
I would say that let let's let's take a
responsible approach to the two issues, OK?
One is schools reopening. There's been eight
mitigation steps that have been announced by
the CDC to implement, right? Yes. Every school
district is going to work to implement those on
a timeline. That is, they can effectively do.
Many school districts are reopening, right. Many
are reopening every single week and day and week.
Right. That is a different circumstance
than what we are seeing at the border.
So bottom line, Peter has a kernel of relevance
wrapped in a veneer of gotcha. And Jen Psaki
often handles parts of it well and then
gets a little flustered for other parts.
She's she's mostly good at appearing calm. Even if
we get the sense that she's frustrated, she does
sort of have to be like the patient mom when the
kids are misbehaving. But the important part is
that this is the culture war sort of framing were
the context for everything is this is hostility
towards law enforcement and deference to teachers
unions, for example. Like that's that's one
cultural element of why this is framed in such
hyperbolic terms, or it's a purported left
wing double standard when the truth is, listen,
circumstances are different in a school versus
in a child migrant facility. And Peter Doocy
will likely keep doing this for as long as
Fox News keeps him in the briefing room. Because
my my instinct is the Fox News viewer sees this
and says, look at that. He's holding Jen Psaki to
account and Jen Psaki is doing a terrible job of
answering these questions. That's my instinct of
how the right sees Peter Deuce's participation in
this. And to the extent that they like it, I would
expect if places like Ohio and Newsmax can get
back in the press briefing room, I would expect
them to do this. But scaled up like 10 notches.